écoutez bonjour bonjour à tous on va
essayer de démarrer à l'heure il est
17h32 ou 3
nous vous remercions de votre présence
je vais donner faire quelques petits
mots un petit mot d'introduction et puis
nous allons passer aux choses sérieuses
après sur
les questionnaires qui vous ont été
envoyés notamment alors mes chers
collègues ici présent nous poursuivons
les travaux de notre mission
d'information sur le développement d'une
filière de biocarburant carburant
synthétique durable et hydrogène vert
par l'audition de Monsieur Pierre
Claquin voilà qui est directeur des
marchés des études et prospectives de
France à Grimmer je dois vous dire que
force agréer est une très belle maison
que je connais un peu et je suis très
heureux de vous accueillir ici
avec donc monsieur Claquin vous êtes
accompagné de Patrick Egra donc qui est
chef de service
analyse et fonction transversale et
multifilaire avec lequel aussi nous
travaillons de temps en temps voilà et
puis par Madame Aurore païen
jeune femme chef d'unité de l'unité
analyse transversale à France Grimal
alors cette réunion est captée sachez-le
et diffusé en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra
ensuite être consultée en vidéo à la
demande de qui le souhaite alors madame
et Messieurs notre émission
d'information
comprend des membres issus de
différentes commissions ici présents qui
représente l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat
le développement des filières de
biocarburant de carburant synthétique
durable et d'hydrogène vert représente
un enjeu important pour permettre à la
France et à l'Union européenne
d'atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais aussi pour
notre souveraineté et la compétitivité
de notre économie
la France vous le savez a développé une
politique ambitieuse en matière de
biocarburant qui a eu des effets
significatifs tant en termes de
production que Dark corporation de
biodiesel ou de bioéthanol dans les
carburants ces orientations se trouvent
aujourd'hui et contestée ou interrogés
par certains et en tout cas par la Cour
des comptes comme par des organisations
non gouvernementales
l'organisation Transport et
Environnement que nous avons auditionné
il y a deux semaines ainsi tenu un
discours très critique sur le bilan des
biocarburants
vous pourrez donc nous faire part de
votre analyse en retour nous nous
intéressons également à la problématique
des conflits d'usage et sur ce point
également nous serons heureux d'entendre
France agrimaire qui je le rappelle
accueille en son sein une commission
thématique interpillière consacrée à la
bio-économie
notre rapporteur monsieur Vincent Kapo
qu'elle est là vous a adressé un
questionnaire
je dirais plutôt danse puisque 20
questions d'orientation mais bien
évidemment il a réellement souhaiter
d'autres mais ça va venir avec chacun
d'entre nous un questionnaire qui vous
servir de guide mais aussi sentez-vous
libre dans vos propos introductifs et en
tout cas les éléments qui pourraient
nous être apportés par la suite et bien
seront les bienvenus pour notre
commission je passe ensuite la parole à
notre rapporteur puis à l'ensemble de
mes collègues afin qu'ils puissent vous
relancer et vous poser un certain nombre
de questions voilà notre mission est en
place maintenant vous pouvez et vous
pouvez transmettre tous vos documents
par la suite monsieur Claquin je vous
cède la parole pour une quinzaine de
minutes
merci ça marche pour le micro c'est bon
merci monsieur le sénateur bon bonjour à
tous
je ferai une introduction assez rapide
et j'essaierai la parole à Aurore on a
préparé un PowerPoint qui présente en
fait l'émission que conduit France à
Grimmer sur la thématique qui est celle
de votre mission je vais rappeler ce qui
est français
ou tutelle du ministère de l'Agriculture
qui a pour mission d'aider les filières
donc les acteurs des filières agricoles
de la pêche et de la co-culture en gros
les filières donc depuis l'amont jusqu'à
Laval jusqu'à la jusqu'à la jusqu'au aux
usages ou aux consommations pour les
pour les filières alimentaires
donc les accompagner à la fois en d'un
point de vue on va dire financier
français gamer est organismes payeur
pour un certain nombre d'aides que ce
soit des aides de l'Union européenne ou
des aides nationales et puis les
accompagner aussi en leur apportant des
éléments d'analyse sur l'évolution des
marchés l'évolution de leur filière les
défis auxquels ils doivent faire face
donc on leur apportant des éléments
d'analyse de manière de manière
objective et en participant également à
la concertation enfin facilité en fait
le dialogue au sein des filières et puis
entre les acteurs des acteurs
professionnels et la sphère publique
donc France agrémer c'est un lieu
d'échange aussi entre les entre les
acteurs entre les acteurs économiques et
les différents départements ministériels
qui peuvent être intéressés pour pour
échanger sur les politiques publiques
qui vont intéresser donc les filières on
a une dimension qui est essentiellement
économique je liens d'introduction ce
qui va certainement de dimensions sur
lesquelles on travaille pas on n'est pas
l'ADEM on n'est pas on n'est pas l'ifpel
on n'a pas une compétence on n'est pas
on n'a pas une compétence énergét
icienne mais on a une compétence plutôt
agricole notre coeur de métier ce sont
les filières et les trajectoires
agricoles voilà on voulait vous
présenter Aurore je vais te laisser la
parole on voulait vous présenter
effectivement ce qu'on fait ce sur quoi
on peut éclairer la mission sur un somme
de dimension on n'a pas toutes les clés
loin de là sur ce sujet mais on a
quelques éléments qui permettent
notamment d'éclairer vous l'avez indiqué
à tout ce qui est notion de conflit
d'usage notamment
donc pour rentrer directement dans le
vif du sujet je vais vous présenter les
sujets concrets à ta FranceAgriMer et ce
qu'on ne traite pas donc ça va être
assez rapide on traite la question des
biocarburants donc qui soit
conventionnel ou avancé donc les
biocarburants sont issus de la biomasse
et on ne traite pas les sujets
d'hydrogène vert et de carburant
synthétiques donc l'hydrogène vert étant
issue de l'électricité qui n'est pas
notre coeur de métier et le carburant
synthétique étant issu de l'hydrogène
mais les voies de synthèse de
l'hydrogène ne sont pas que la biomasse
donc pour l'instant c'est quelque chose
qu'on suit d'un point de vue veille mais
on n'a pas d'éléments à vous apporter
sur l'hydrogène vert et les carburants
synthétiques
donc le l'objet de ma présentation va
porter uniquement sur les biocarburants
donc aussi un introduction les données
qu'on produit et les données qui sont
hors de notre champ d'action donc toutes
les données qu'on traite sont issues en
fait de la statistique agricole et
alimentaires donc beaucoup de données
issues de la politique agricole commune
donc ça nous permet d'avoir des
statistiques sur les surfaces sur les
rendements les productions etc et sur
certains
usages et notamment les usages
alimentaires mais mais pas que on essaye
on y reviendra et donc tout ce qui est
volumes de biocarburant enfin de
carburant et avec les volumes incorporés
dans ces carburants là les biocarbures
incorporés dans les carburants ça c'est
des statistiques qui sont plutôt du côté
ministère de l'Environnement donc on est
en échange avec eux mais c'est pas des
données qui sont produites à France
agrément
il y a aussi
certaines questions ce qui sont sous
secrets statistiques donc France
agrimaire ne mesure pas donc ça va être
typiquement l'usage du sucre en
biocarburant il y a pas assez d'acteurs
en France pour publier les données
là-dessus donc France agréer ne mesure
pas ses données par respect du secret
statistique donc tout ça on n'aura pas
des données là-dessus mais en fait parce
qu'on respecte la loi quoi donc à France
agréer comme le disait en introduction
pierre on a quand même un axe économique
fort donc on fait de la conjoncture sur
les biocarburants donc on nous regarde
les cours les prix notamment des
matières premières et les échanges qui
sont faits sur les marchés
internationaux et on a des éléments pour
juger la compétitivité des filières
biocarburants donc en France et sur
certains pays étrangers sur lesquels on
fait un focus
donc comme le disait pierre on regarde
pas les aspects environnementaux santé
etc qui ne sont pas dans l'émission à
proprement parler de français
on peut faire de la veille via nos
groupes de travail
donc sur les biomasse étudiés on regarde
les cultures dédiées à des usages non
alimentaires tout ce qui est coproduit
des industries agroalimentaires et les
résidus de culture
la forêt le bois sont suivies plus
particulièrement par l'Institut
Géographique nationale qui s'appelle pas
tout à fait comme ça et l'ADEME et
pareil les déchir urbains aménagés sont
coté Adam donc France agrimaire un rôle
via une base de données que je vais vous
présenter d'agrégateurs de données
publiques mais on ne traite pas
spécifiquement ces ressources là
donc j'ai mis ici des définitions de la
bio économie mais vu que j'ai 15 minutes
je vais aller très rapidement sur le
fait que la bio économie a une
définition assez large puisque c'est
l'utilisation la transformation des
ressources
issues de la photosynthèse y compris de
manière indirecte via les animaux et
qu'à France agrimaire on a un
[Musique]
enfin l'unité bio économie à France
agrimaire s'occupe spécifiquement des
usages non alimentaires parce que
historiquement français de la fusion des
offices agricoles donc on a déjà des
unités qui sont dédiées aux filières
alimentaires donc nous on est sur de la
complémentarité donc
bon ça va pour les bio-carburants c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on mange donc je
vais pouvoir vous en parler
l'émission donc je vais pas reprendre
tout ce que disait pierre mais on a
trois gros volets à France agrimaire
donc étudier analyser avec la production
de données économiques sur différentes
filières concerté avec notre mission
enfin l'organisation de groupes de
travail notamment sur la question des
biocarburants et accompagner mais on n'a
pas d'outils spécifiques à
france-agrumeur pour accompagner d'un
point de vue financier les filières mais
France agrumeur est un format en place
des dispositifs de France 2030
donc pour la bio économie et notamment
pour ce qui est des biocarburants on va
être sur le volet étudié analysé et
concerté donc je vais aller plus en
détail sur ces missions là
donc ça c'était un récapitulatif rapide
de ce qu'on faisait dans l'unité bio
économie à FranceAgriMer donc sur le
volet étudier analysé on a une base de
données que je vous présenterai qui est
l'Observatoire national des ressources
en biomasse donc il cherche à quantifier
les gisements de matières premières et
d'indiquer les différents usages qui
sont faits quand ils sont connus
on produit des fiches filières sur le
bioéthanol et le biogazole donc c'est
disponible sur le site de français
grammaire et une note de conjoncture
également sur les biocarburants
en ce qui concerne le volet concertation
on a un observatoire des marchés donc
sur les biocarburants encore mais aussi
sur des coproduits animaux et on invite
des intervenants extérieurs donc sur les
actualités réglementaires et d'autres
sujets d'actualité pour en discuter avec
les professionnels
et on a un troisième axe qui est un axe
d'étude donc on finance des études qui
vont être menées par des prestataires
externes pour alimenter nos deux volets
étudianalisés et concertés donc on a
notamment une veille concurrentielle sur
les biocarburants qui je pense va vous
intéresser
donc pour ce qui est de la concertation
on a une commission thématique
interfiliaire sur la bio-économie donc
c'est vraiment tous les sujets
transversaux à la bio économie et du
coup il y a quatre groupes de travail
qui sont plus spécifiquement à axé sur
des sujets donc notamment les
biocarburants donc la commission
thématique interfiliaire se réunit deux
fois par an et les groupes de travail 2
à 3 fois par an
et donc ces groupes de travail
rassemblent à la fois les représentants
des administrations et des
professionnels et des experts enfin un
peu toute personne pertinente sur le
sujet
donc dans ce groupe de travail
biocarburant on traite plus
spécifiquement de certaines matières
premières donc les céréales betteraves
canne à sucre qui vont produire du
bioéthanol pour les biocarbures en
conventionnels les
oléoprotéagineux pour la production
biogazole toujours pour les biocarbures
en conventionnels et des matières
premières qui ententes dans les
biocarburants avancés donc les marillis
la mélasse les graisses animales les
yeux l'usagers
on ne traite pas spécifiquement l'hydro
traitement des huiles donc la HVO qui
est une technologie détenue par les
pétroliers et on n'a pas de
représentants des pétroliers au sein de
notre groupe de travail
donc pas c'était une des questions de
que vous posiez donc concernant la ce
qu'on appelle la 1g donc on traite
spécifiquement spécifiquement la
question de la 1g au sein première
génération ouais
au sein d'un groupe de travail les
résidus cellulosiques les algues sont
actuellement en cours de développement
donc c'est un sujet qu'on traite enfin
qu'on regarde mais on n'a pas d'outils
spécifiques dessus pour le moment c'est
pas encore à une échelle industrielle
telle que
qu'on a des choses dessus quoi
donc très rapidement des grandes
thématiques qu'on aborde dans le groupe
de travail biocarburant donc on a des
actualités réglementaires et politiques
publiques donc on a vite les
administrations à s'exprimer donc il y a
tous les ans un bilan qui est fait de la
tire verte par la DGDDI et le bilan
d'incorporation des biocarburants de la
DGEC
on invite des experts à s'exprimer sur
certains sujets donc par exemple cette
année on a eu l'IFPEN et Axens plus
particulièrement qui sont venus nous
présenter les différentes technologies
de production de biocarburant avancés
donc ils nous présentait les différentes
biomasses et vers quelle procéder
elle pouvait être orientée pour produire
certains types de biocarburant donc là
on fait appel à des experts externes ce
qu'on produit en propre à FranceAgriMer
c'est l'Observatoire des marchés des
biocarburants
excusez-moi donc à chaque GT on a une
chargée de mission qui présente la
conjoncture sur les principaux
producteurs de biocarburant donc c'est
un exercice économique avec des suivis
de cours de prix voilà de volume
et vous pouvez retrouver sur le site de
France agramer toutes les études
ponctuelles qu'on peut faire sur une
thématique des biocarburants ou de la
bio économie au sens large et cette
mission éclairée
on la présente aussi aux professionnels
quand on a des choses intéressantes pour
eux
donc pour l'éclairage de cette question
des conflits d'usage on a deux outils
qui peuvent être utiles donc le premier
c'est la veille qu'on fait sur les
facteurs de compétitivité du marché
international des biocarburants donc ce
qu'on appelle communément la veille
biocarburant son objectif c'est
d'identifier les facteurs qui
influencent la compétitivité de la
France et de ses concurrents
donc par rapport aux questions que vous
posez dans le questionnaire on a
notamment une estimation des surfaces
agricoles qui sont utilisés pour la
production de biocarburant en France et
dans le monde
cette veille du coup
identifie les forces et faiblesses des
pays compétiteurs afin de suivre les
évolution du marché la compétitivité de
ces acteurs là et on classe les pays en
fonction des différents indicateurs donc
je vais vous présenter un résumé de
cette veille juste après
le deuxième outil qu'on a c'est notre
base de données l'Observatoire des
nationales des ressources en biomast qui
a pour objectif d'identifier de
quantifier les ressources en biomasse
disponibles et la question qui se pose
c'est quels usage sont faits de ces
ressources et du coup qu'est-ce qui
reste pour de nouveaux usages c'est un
outil qui a pour but d'éclairer les
pouvoirs publics donc si jamais il y a
besoin d'arbitrage sur différentes
questions et d'anticiper certains
problèmes certaines tensions qui peuvent
apparaître sur des biomasses
donc concernant la veille biocarburant
elle se décline en 6 axes de
compétitivité donc le potentiel de
production des pays les conditions agro
climatiques de ces pays les capacités
des opérateurs des filières leur
portefeuille de marché leur organisation
et l'environnement macroéconomique donc
chaque axe est décliné en plusieurs
indicateurs et
on obtient une note synthétique à la fin
donc un résumé très rapide de cette
veille c'est que la France est en
compétition avec des pays qui ont un
plus fort taux d'incorporation de
biocarburant donc par exemple 32% de
bioéthanol au Brésil certains pays ont
un plus fort soutien public donc par
exemple la Thaïlande qui a une politique
de développement de son marché
interne finalement via
la généralisation de véhicules
compatibles E20 et E85
et certains pays ont des mesures
restrictives sur l'importation de
biocarburant donc toujours la Thaïlande
qui limite les importations de bio
diesel
certains pays sont très actifs dans le
domaine de la R&D donc c'est notamment
le cas des États-Unis donc on considère
que c'est plutôt un atout pour ces pays
là
certains pays ont un marché intérieur
qui est déjà plus développé que le nôtre
donc là on a les États-Unis pour le
biodiesel
des capacités à l'export qui peuvent
être supérieurs à nous donc toujours les
États-Unis pour le bioéthanol et
l'Allemagne pour le biodyssel
et également en fonction du mix de
matière première qui est utilisée
la France peut être en compétition avec
des acteurs qui ont des ressources
moins chères ou un environnement
agroécologique enfin qui permet de
d'avoir moins besoin d'apprendre d'être
moins soumis à des pathogènes etc
donc là l'exemple que je donnais c'était
le Canada qui avait des grosses réserves
en eau et une pression pathogène
contrôlée donc c'était plutôt un atout
pour la culture
notamment de colza
voilà donc là c'est un résumé très
rapide et on a publié en ligne les trois
dernières veilles et si vous avez besoin
on peut vous imprimer la dernière qui
est en train d'être mise en page donc si
vous avez envie on peut vous l'envoyer
donc je vais faire un focus sur les
surfaces agricoles utilisées par les
biocarburants donc il était une des
questions de dans votre questionnaire
donc ça fait partie de l'axe 1 de notre
veille donc je vais vous présenter la
méthode de calcul pour l'obtenir donc on
part des volumes de biocarburant qui
sont produits dans un pays par exemple
la France mais tous les pays qu'on
étudie dans cette veille
on regarde le mix de matière première
utilisée dans ce pays là ça nous permet
d'estimer des volumes de biocarburant
par type de matières premières
à partir de ces volumes par matières
premières on le transforme ça
en matière première produite sur le
territoire de ce pays-là parce qu'il y a
des importations des exportations de
matières premières aussi
à partir des matières premières des
volumes de matières premières produite
par un pays on obtient le tonnage
à partir du tonnage les surfaces et à ce
moment là on va séparer en fait
le pourcentage de la plante qui va par
exemple partir en alimentation animale
ou pour d'autres usages et on va garder
enfin on applique un coefficient pour
garder que
un équivalent surface qui part
spécifiquement biocarburant donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle une surface ce qu'on
appelle nous la surface nette de
coproduit c'est à dire qu'on a enlevé
tous les autres usages de la matière
première puisque une matière première ne
part pas exclusivement en biocarburant
il y a une partie
je sais pas les drêches elles vont
partir en alimentation animale et on va
garder que le grain
donc j'ai rassemblé ici dans un tableau
pour le biogazole tous les pays qu'on
suit dans la veille donc avec la France
ce qu'on peut voir déjà c'est qu'à
l'échelle mondiale
c'est en légère augmentation mais c'est
assez faible puisque 0,3% de la surface
agricole utile mondiale
net de co-produit et utilisé pour la
production biocarburant
on a une augmentation en 2019 qui a
attribuable en fait à l'augmentation de
la culture de palme dédiée au
biocarburant notamment en Indonésie et
un petit peu en Malaisie mais c'est un
petit peu ça aussi un peu plus comme
vous pouvez le voir
ce qu'on peut voir en France c'est que
la surface est plutôt tendance à
diminuer mais bon comme vous voyez
l'ordre de grandeur reste le même on est
vers 3% quoi de la SAV
et malgré le fait que nos surfaces
diminuent on est encore un acteur
important en Europe sur ce marché là
donc j'imagine que vous aurez la diapo
donc
si vous voulez récupérer les chiffres
pour le bioéthanol donc même constat les
surfaces mondiales sont relativement
faibles
par rapport surface agricole totale
relativement stable et puis on a
vraiment
les États-Unis qui sont
j'ai pas mis les pourcentages de
production mais on n'est pas du tout
dans la même catégorie quoi c'est je
crois que c'est 50% de la production qui
vient de des États-Unis
donc ils ont des surfaces en conséquence
un petit peu plus élevées que les autres
et en France c'est stable
alors sur cette diapo vous avez le
détail des des gisements qui vont dans
un biocarburant donc
pour 2019 2009 et 2019 donc en gros en
45%
des biocarburants venaient du maïs en
2019 c'est 42 43%
ce qu'on voit du coup c'est que le maïs
est la principale matière première
utilisée sachant que c'est enfin c'est
dû aux Etats-Unis en fait puisque les
États-Unis utilisent massivement du maïs
pour le bioéthanol
ce qui peut être intéressant de noter
c'est que la palme est en augmentation
en disant elle est passée de 1,4% des
surfaces donc net de coproduit toujours
à presque 9%
que les le tournesol qui est dont
l'huile peut partir en alimentation
humaine ABC pour atteindre 0,2% 2019
la betterave donc qui n'était pas non
plus un fort pourcentage parce que
c'était 0,5% à diminué donc ça c'est ça
s'explique aussi par des difficultés
d'un point de vue pathogène donc il y a
eu d'autres matières premières qui ont
été utilisées à la place
le colza donc qui est moins utilisé en
alimentation humaine mais un petit peu
et passer de 8,4 à 7,1 et le blé est
environ stable enfin les céréales et
c'est assez marginal à l'échelle
mondiale
je pense que je vous ai tout dit sur
cette diapo
donc là on regarde les surfaces
agricoles donc l'évolution entre
toujours net de coproduit entre 2009 et
donc on voit que la canne à sucre enfin
c'est
15% des
[Musique]
oui
c'est ça il manque
d'affichage mais en gros on a sur on a
les valeurs en pourcentage
n'apparaissent pas là sur le graphique
pour la canne on est passé à 25 % je
crois à 20 on est passé de 15 à 21
pour la Palme on est passé de 2,7 à 18
presque 19 donc très forte hausse pour
la Palme
maïs légère hausse puisqu'on passe de
5,5 à 8
soja c'est mineur donc 7,3 à 8,1
colza c'est environ stable betterave ça
a été divisé par deux
on est passé à 1,2%
tournesol également divisé par 2 mais on
partait de pas beaucoup d'hectares
manioc une augmentation donc on passe de
0 à 0,5%
et céréales on passe de 0,1 à 0,2%
voilà donc
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut voir c'est
effectivement les ordres de grandeur
c'est diapositive elle est intéressante
elle vous montre bien par rapport aux
précédentes pour être sûr d'avoir bien
fait passer le message on est sur la
part de la surface mondiale de la
culture concernée qui est dédiée au
carburant et on voit si vous regardez le
blé on est on est à 0 % c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment pas c'est prend pas un
sujet pour au passage pour les cultures
alimentaires parce que même le maïs en
l'occurrence c'est pas assez c'est une
culture alimentation humaine c'est
principalement quand même dans le monde
une culture dédiée à l'alimentation à
l'alimentation du bétail pareil pour le
soja également et on voit que le fait
notable des dernières années ce qu'il
faut vraiment retenir c'est la
progression très très forte de la palme
pour le coup c'est on voit que sur les
sur les sur les productions on va dire
occidentales on est sur une forme de de
maturité des marchés que ce soit
que ce soit en sucre ou en ou
oléagineux au soja colza ou les céréales
mais par contre c'est vraiment sur la
palme on a une progression très très
forte dans le monde c'est vraiment par
là que c'est fait c'est fait de la
progression ces dernières années sur les
sur les surfaces
vous voulez démontrer qu'il y a pas de
concurrence entre aliments usage
alimentaire et non alimentaires au
niveau des surfaces sans risque là en
tout cas on voit que pour les cultures
alimentaires on est vraiment sur des sur
des fractions très très limitées genre
le blé c'est pas on n'a pas un problème
de concurrence sur le blé en tout cas ça
il y a pas de pas vraiment de sujet à
l'échelle mondiale ça reste ça reste
vraiment le blé c'est une spécificité
française au passage la production de de
de bio à partir de blé et c'est très
très peu présent dans le monde les
principales cultures voyant ça va être
soit des cultures dédiées comme la palme
soit des cultures enfin les oléagineux
des oléagineux qui vont être
multi-usages je rappelle le soja aussi
pareil la principale valorisation du
soja elle est quand même essentiellement
en alimentation animale aussi c'est les
tourteaux
la canne effectivement pour le coup la
canne et à la canne à double phare
la canne ici c'est principalement Brésil
aussi au passage on l'a dit le enfin sur
le sur le ce qu'il faut voir en la
production la production de de de
diesel et réparti dans pas mal de pays
on a quand même quelques gros acteurs on
le voit dans la veille concurrentielle
on a l'Argentine on a les pays européens
on a les pays donc de sud-est pour le
coup c'est ce qu'a dit Aurore sur le sur
le bioéthanol on est vraiment il y a
deux mastodontes et puis le reste du
monde très clairement il y a les
États-Unis le Brésil et le reste du
monde vraiment c'est très très très très
marqué c'est très très binaire pour le
pour le bioéthanol
là je passe à mon autre outil de veille
l'omrb donc l'Observatoire national des
ressources en biomasse c'est notre base
qui est recense les gisements
et leurs usages
donc on a une grande diversité de
produits dedans donc si je vous le
présente aujourd'hui c'est parce que les
résidus agricoles je pense vous
intéresse par rapport à au biocarburant
de deuxième génération et les deux
carburants avancés
donc à noter que dans cet outil on n'a
pas le bois puisque c'est côté
l'Institut national de l'information
géographique et forestière avec leur
outil cartophobe
on a les algues aussi qui sont en train
d'être ajoutés on a quelques données sur
les années
pour une future troisième génération un
jour
quand l'outil cartophobe sera mis à
disposition on pourra
rassembler les données mais nous on ne
produit pas de données sur le bois on
produit
des estimations donc je vais vous
expliquer comment est-ce qu'on estime
les différents gisements mais surtout
sur l'agriculture puisqu'on a les
données de la Pâques qui nous ramène des
données chaque année pour les industries
agroalimentaires on utilise des
coefficients
et la biomasse aquatique qu'on a fait
une étude récemment donc qui nous a
donné des coefficients donc qui va nous
permettre de de creuser cet aspect là et
on les intègre petit à petit dans le NRB
et donc de ce point de vue là on a
quelques enfin en fait c'est un travail
continu d'intégrer de nouvelles biomass
dans cette base de données et donc on a
des pistes sur les algues mais voilà
c'est en cours c'est toujours en cours
donc comment on fait donc on part d'un
volume total produit donc quand on peut
des données statistiques de
l'ASP enfin voilà de la PAC du ministère
de l'Agriculture
quand on n'a pas la donner on peut se
tourner vers les professionnels
ensuite on passe à une étape le volume
théorique disponible en fait on va
enlever tous les volumes qui ne sont pas
récoltables donc ça va être par exemple
la hauteur de coupe de la paille
fonction de la hauteur de coupe n'a pas
la même quantité de masse à la fin
un animal qui pâture ses effluents vont
pas être récupérables lorsqu'ils donc ça
influe sur les gisements etc
ensuite deuxième étape d'estimation
c'est d'enlever tous les usages connus
donc l'alimentation les matériaux
l'énergie l'agronomie donc on a le
retour au sol
voilà pour garder une fertilité des sols
donc on considère que c'est un usage
prioritaire et on obtient un volume
supplémentaire disponible pour de
nouveaux usages
donc ça peut être intéressant d'un point
de vue
politique publique de voir quel est le
potentiel de croissance sur un jugement
donc attention tous les usages ne sont
pas connus donc sur notre volume
supplémentaire disponible il y a une
part en fonction de la biomasse qui est
en fait peut être utilisé c'est juste
qu'on en a pas connaissance
tous les critères sont pas pris en
compte dans le calcul ou par exemple
le coût de la récolte donc si je sais
pas si le prix des carburants augmente
peut-être que l'agriculteur va pas juger
utile d'aller récupérer de la paille sur
son champ parce que ça va lui coûter en
carburant et en temps de travail
il y a aussi une propension à offrir qui
est pas mesurée par exemple si vous avez
une enfin par exemple exemple de la
forêt c'est pas parce que vous avez une
forêt que vous allez forcément
l'exploiter à son maximum donc il y a en
fait la conclusion de cette diapo c'est
que c'est une estimation
pour être très clair c'est en fait quand
on fait c'est une estimation bio
physique c'est-à-dire qu'en gros on va
voir les vols on va travailler en volume
on travaille pas on travaille pas en
valeur au sens économique du terme ça on
n'a pas les valorisations associées on
n'a pas les coûts associés donc on sait
pas effectivement si
économiquement ce serait intéressant
d'aller
récolter ou valoriser le supplément
disponible c'est vraiment assez grand
une analyse en volume pardon avec
l'autorisation du président juste une
question surtout ces données
ce type d'observatoire pour nous est
très précieux est-ce que vous pourrez
justement nous renseigner sur à la fois
les volumes constatés et puis ce que
vous estimez comme potentiel de volume
supplémentaires puisque la question que
se la mission c'est quel est le quel est
l'état actuel donc là vous avez des
observations qui sont très utiles et
quel est le potentiel et comment on voit
l'avenir
des biocarbures puisque parfois on
entend dire et le Président il a fait
allusion tout à l'heure alors je parlais
prudence que le président est un
excellent
connaisseur du sujet il a il a commis
comme on dit entre nous un excellent
rapport qui fait référence mais la
question qu'on se pose c'est
effectivement
que faut-il penser de ceux qui disent
que les Bleus carburants ont atteint un
palier un plafond
parfois et certains
vont jusqu'à nous dire ou du moins quand
on lit par exemple le rapport de la Cour
des comptes on peut même se poser la
question de savoir si c'est pas un
toboggan je le dis de manière un peu
brutale pour poser des bas mais je vous
laisse continuer veiller peut-être à
nous donner ce genre d'éléments et en
tout cas nous renseigner sur
les données actuelles et ce que vous
pensez du potentiel je peux compléter la
question du rapporteur c'est combien
d'énergie consommée pour une énergie
produite
pour commencer un peu en amont de la
question il faut bien voir que cet outil
là pour ce quelques questions
statistiques un peu bêtes mais qui sont
pas simples à résoudre ici il faut il
s'agit d'additionner des choux et des
carottes donc le choix de l'unité n'est
pas n'est pas absolument neutre est-ce
qu'on raisonne en tonnage ce qu'on fait
ce qu'on assied est-ce qu'on agglomère
des tonnes de biomasse dans tous les
sens sachant que ça a pas grand sens si
vous faites ça avec de par exemple du
bois si vous savez pas si c'est du bois
humide ou du bois sec en matière par
exemple énergétique ça veut strictement
rien dire si vous n'avez pas le taux
d'humidité du bois ça n'a aucun sens
donc il faut déjà travailler à rendre
les données comparables soit en termes
de tonnage soit en termes de contenu
énergétique c'est les deux seules unités
pour l'instant qui nous permettent
d'agglomérer des choses de nature
différente mais ça pose des grosses
questions on n'est pas encore aussi au
niveau de valorisation dans cet outil
dans cet outil comme le disait pierre
les
les données ne sont pas
monétisées on n'a pas les on n'a pas les
prix or par exemple pour l'extraction de
molécules d'intérêt qui peuvent être des
aspects de gestion de la biomasse qui
sont tout à fait intéressants voilà
c'est pas les volumes qui comptent c'est
bien évidemment les prix sur des
molécules particulières qui peuvent
aller en chimie ou en cosmétiques donc
ça c'est la première chose secondaire
c'est un outil de constatation alors
bien sûr on a on a accumulé des
informations on les a rendu public
depuis en 2012 2016 2020 et depuis
annuellement on les actualise d'accord
donc on a quelques données qui nous
permettent d'avoir un peu de recul voilà
si je suis un statisticien très attentif
et je vais vous dire qu'on a pas assez
de recul pour faire des projections
voilà parce que normalement pour faire
du temps une variable explicative mais
professeurs de statistiques m'avaient
dit qu'il fallait 30 ans donc voilà donc
on les a pas les 30 ans encore voilà ça
c'est ça c'est une première difficulté
ensuite on peut scénariser les choses on
peut tenter de faire des hypothèses et
se servir de cette base de données pour
voir ce que ça donnerait si on faisait
ceci ou si on faisait cela si on
développait par exemple lessives les
cultures intermédiaires vocation
énergétiques enfin il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut faire à
partir de ces outils mais ce n'est pas
un outil c'est pas une prospective c'est
pas un outil qui c'est un outil qui
permet qui permettrait d'être utilisé
dans le cas d'une réflexion prospective
mais en tant que telle c'est pas un
outil qui donne des résultats projectifs
voilà
oui merci de bon enfin on va peut-être
laisser
terminer sa présentation mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que vous avez des outils
formidables et on sait que vous êtes un
opérateur majeur et qui est une source
de ressources pour nous et des cadrage
mais la question qu'on se pose c'est
dans le cas de la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie de la révision qui
va intervenir là à l'été nous
semble-t-il qu'est-ce que les éléments
que vous avez vous accumulés peuvent
nous fournir comme
constat hypothèse orientation pour
valider une stratégie globale de
décarbonation et valider la part que les
biocarburants peuvent avoir dans cette
stratégie globale de décarbonation c'est
ça notre axe nous notre question alors
évidemment vous ne pouvez contribuer à
cette réflexion que à la mesure des
éléments que vous avez et on va pas vous
instrumentaliser vous êtes une opérateur
de l'État mais tout ce que vous pouvez
nous dire qui nous aidera à
collectivement à construire cette
réflexion elle sera appréciée par les
mondes de la mission voilà vous voulez
peut-être
après effectivement on a été interrogé
par nos collègues pour fournir un les
données de 2020 pour la SNBC notamment
donc là on avait sorti tous les enfin un
certain nombre de volumes sur les
résidus ceux qui les intéressait les
volumes de biocarburant donc là c'est
issus de la veille que je vous ai
présenté et après ce que ça donne dans
leur modèle etc ça moi je suis pas au
courant mais en tout cas on est
interrogé par nos collègues là dessus ce
que je voulais dire c'est que c'était
des données publiques après si vous avez
besoin de plus de détails en fait il va
falloir nous préciser quel gisement vous
voulez parce que comme vous voyez un peu
sur cette diapo on a beaucoup de de
matières premières qu'on suit donc si
vous avez fait un diaporama
complet sur toutes les données de loi
normée vous m'auriez coupé la parole
avant que je fasse le tour
donc en tout cas il y a pas de souci on
prend les on prend les commandes sur le
NRB
c'est un petit peu ce que disait Patrick
c'est déjà pas sur le fait qu'en fait
les orientations politiques qu'elles
soient économiques environnementales ou
sociale vont influer le système agricole
et les rotations mises en oeuvre qui
vont à leur tour influer sur la quantité
de biomasse produite et c'est ça qu'on
va pouvoir mesurer dans le NRB on va
mesurer
les gisements produits
chaque année
et qui sont influés par d'autres choses
mais nous on n'a pas à la main sur les
intentions politiques et après le NRB
sert à éclairer d'autres orientations
politiques donc par exemple
est-ce que il faut favoriser les
biocarburants par rapport à d'autres
usages
est-ce qu'au contraire il faut regarder
des questions de souveraineté est-ce que
il y a des valeurs des usages à plus
forte valeur ajoutée qu'il faudrait
favoriser etc et ça c'est des
orientations politiques pour lequel
l'ONRB donne juste des volumes mais
c'est pas nous ensuite qui
pouvons vous aider là-dessus
on va être un peu un peu déceptif un
certainement pour vous sur ces questions
là mais je le rappelais on n'est pas on
n'est pas énergéticien je vais y arriver
déjà j'arrive pas à prononcer le terme
et donc il y a une grande partie des
dimensions du sujet qui sont qu'on ne
maîtrise pas qu'on connaît pas et qu'on
a d'ailleurs pas forcément vocation à
connaître ce qu'on va faire au sein de
France agrimaire c'est deux choses c'est
contribuer à éclairer une partie de ces
sujets là notamment à travers l'endroit
la mobilisation la biomasse agricole
c'est ça qu'on va éclairer
principalement c'est ça qu'on vous a
qu'on vous a présenté et la deuxième
chose qu'on peut faire à France
agrimaire c'est aussi mettre en
discussion ces sujets là pour le coup
avec les avec les différentes familles
professionnelles et c'est ce qu'on fait
régulièrement au sein de la CTI et de
ces groupes de travail c'est-à-dire
qu'on va
on va conduire ou pas ou faire faire
inter- faire pardon interagir les les
ministères donc on fait on fait
intervenir régulièrement la DGEC sur le
sujet
à la fois sur les évolutions
réglementaires mais également aussi sur
sur un certain nombre de dessus
d'intérêt on a eu sur ces questions un
peu d'orientation générale de
à la fois à la fois énergétique en
l'occurrence également aussi alimentaire
on a fait intervenir l'ADEME aussi sur
lors de la dernière commission
thématique interpilière sur ces
scénarios
prospectifs pour pouvoir échanger avec
les familles professionnelles on n'a pas
forcément un avis à formuler sur le
sujet parce qu'il y a encore une période
et les dimensions qu'on va pas maîtriser
par contre on a vocation à faire
discuter
en l'occurrence l'ADN qui avait produit
scénario avec les avec les acteurs
professionnels et les pouvoirs publics
j'en profite sur la version sur le volet
politique publique on est aussi je l'ai
dit on a un établissement public ou
tutelle du mystère et culture une partie
des champs d'intervention et en
l'occurrence une bonne partie des champs
intervention sur les sujets biocarburant
c'est des choix d'intervention pour
lesquels c'est le ministère écologique
et compétent donc on est aussi un peu
tributaire de la nos échanges avec le
ministère écologique et pas notre
ministère du sel donc on échange avec
eux on a très bons échanges et il
participe à nos groupes mais on n'est
pas on n'est pas un opérateur de du
ministère écologique non plus donc on a
une partie de dimension sur lesquels on
va pouvoir échanger avec eux il y a une
partie des des sujets qui vont qui vont
nécessairement nous échapper comme l'a
dit Aurore les dimensions qu'on les
dimensions de souveraineté on a vu que
ça revenait très fortement sur le devant
de la scène avec la avec la avec la
guerre en
Ukraine c'est les dimensions qu'on va
pas compétents pour traiter or on sait
qu'ils sont importants à traiter il faut
les intégrer dans la réflexion et nous
France animer on n'a pas cette
compétence là on a pu travailler sur la
souveraineté alimentaire parce que c'est
des champs sur lesquels on peut en
maîtriser davantage les différentes les
différentes données du problème pour le
coup la souveraineté énergétique ou les
ou les priorités ou la décarbonation
énergétique on n'a pas toutes les on n'a
pas tous les données pour pouvoir
répondre au sujet il y en a d'autres il
y a d'autres établissements qui sont
plus compétents que nous pour le faire
là on arrive alors
dans le micro désolé j'introduis le
schéma avant de vous avant de laisser
Patrick le présenter ça c'est un élément
qu'on a voulu mettre en vous soumettre
en tout cas sur les impacts qui peuvent
exister et les multiples relations entre
les prix les prix énergétiques et les
prix alimentaires parce que c'est un
sujet du débat souvent sur les
biocarburants ça c'est un sujet qui est
qui existe depuis au moins 20 ans à ma
connaissance donc ça ça fait ça fait un
moment
qui est peut-être pas complètement
tranché et on va on va essayer de voir
pourquoi d'ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas
facile à c'est pas facile à trancher ce
sujet là parce qu'il y a de multiples
d'interactions entre les entre les prix
des productions agricoles et puis les et
puis les prix des les prix d'énergie et
les produits pétroliers en particulier
je te laisse Patrick peut-être le
présenter
je sais pas trop long vous avez sur
schéma en bas les principales ressources
agricoles qui servent à fabriquer soit
d'un côté
des sucres et par fermentation des
alcools soit de l'autre côté des huiles
et pas rester efficace les produits qui
vont rentrer dans le biogazole voyez
vous voyez qu'en réalité on a très
rapidement une interférence qui se fait
avec l'alimentation animale et là
l'alimentation humaine ce qui est pas
une vraie surprise soit directement soit
indirectement avec les coproductions
notamment si on prend sur le colza il y
a une grande partie de la production de
colza qui va autour tôt et qui va en
alimentation animale voilà on peut
passer on peut passer rapidement aux
choses donc première interférence avec
avec qui crée un lien entre les prix des
produits les prix les prix des prix
alimentaires c'est le fait que
il y a une influence sur les coûts de
production bien sûr de l'engrais de la
médialisation et il y a voilà
l'actualité et la guerre en UK bien
démontré que c'était un des facteurs
d'inflation des produits alimentaires ça
c'est absolument clair et puis il y a
aussi le fait qu'il y a une existence
d'opérateurs qui ont des portefeuilles
qui comprennent à la fois des produits
agricoles et produits alimentaires y
compris même et y compris bien sûr sur
les marchés à terme et que ces gens
jouent de la substitution et de des
évolutions de prix entre ces différents
produits donc ça c'est des liens
économiques relativement direct
ce qu'on peut remarquer également et on
va passer à autre transparence plus
rapidement c'est qu'il y a d'autres
politiques publiques qui créent des
liens
structurels entre entre ces différents
productions agricoles et les prix
pétroliers c'est bien sûr les règles
d'assemblage de l'incorporation
vous êtes au cœur de ce débat et vous
connaissez bien ce débat mais c'est tout
à fait important il y a aussi les
incitations à l'économie circulaire qui
vont qui vont permettre ou non suivant
qu'on double compte ou qu'on double
compte pas les produits qui vont rentrer
qui vont bénéficier des exonérations
fiscales etc il y a aussi des problèmes
qui sont des problèmes un peu plus
compliqués et qui créent aussi de la
complexité sur ça c'est d'abord des
problèmes de vitesse de maturité
technologique on parle bien évidemment
de la deuxième génération et on parle de
la troisième génération pour l'instant
la deuxième génération vous savez on
parle des TRL c'est à dire des des
niveaux de pour passer de la recherche à
la mise en application industrielle
globalement il y a ce qu'on appelle dans
les TRL la vallée de la mort c'est à
dire lorsqu'on sort des terrarielles 5-6
avant d'arriver à l'industrialisation et
bien il y a parfois des projets pour les
si on n'arrive pas à les industrialiser
parce que ça marche très bien aussi de
pilote mais quand on passe à l'industrie
ça ne marche pas et ben il se trouve que
pour la 2G pour l'instant il semble
qu'on est un peu coincé là alors que ça
marche on labo ça marche on se pilote
mais voilà ça marche pas en terme
industriel et ça ça pose un problème et
pour la 3G aussi on a alors il y a pour
la 3G par contre il y a déjà des
quelques installations industrielles qui
existent sur les micro-ag mais ça coûte
relativement cher en termes énergétique
et puis le dernier point qui crée de la
complexité c'est la demande future en
produits animaux notamment on voit bien
que si demain si on reprend les
prospectives qui ont été faites par
exemple notamment par l'ADEME sur
l'évolution des systèmes alimentaires si
demain la consommation de produits
carnés diminue bah il est pas absolument
certain que la production la
coproduction d'huile et de tourteau soit
maintenu au même niveau bien évidemment
puisque une partie de l'intérêt
économique de la production konosa c'est
aussi le fait de nourrir des animaux à
partir des tourteaux et que ça
d'ailleurs ça contribue à l'indépendance
protéique de la France
et donc il est clair que si on diminue
l'alimentation animale il n'est pas
certain que sera pas un effet sur la
production d'huile et or la production
d'huile en France pour les pour le pour
le bio diesel c'est principalement du
colza donc on voit bien que
expliciter clairement un lien direct et
facile et tu peux passer aux
transparence
la peau suivante c'est c'est assez
compliqué par ailleurs simplement sur le
plan informatique et sur le plan
scientifique les éléments qui sont
marqués d'un Astérix là sont les
éléments pour lesquels il y a le plus de
publications scientifique le plus
d'articles qui sont sortis maintenant
sur le reste sur l'évolution de la
maturité technologique l'incitation à
l'économie circulaire les contraintes à
l'apport ou de durabilité qu'on voit
aujourd'hui par exemple on a les
Français en la France a comment
s'appelle à renoncer à l'importation de
ville de palme à cette destination etc
et au soja au lieu de soja mais on voit
bien que il reste encore plein de choses
qui rentrent très complexes l'analyse
directe du lien entre les prix
pétroliers et les prix alimentaires
voilà le but de ce graphique là c'était
de vous montrer que il y a plein de
choses qui influent sur le sujet et
qu'il n'y en a que quelques unes qui
sont très clairement éclairées par des
publications
scientifiques digne de ce nom voilà
et alors c'était déjà une usine à gaz au
départ votre votre tableau ou en tout
cas bioéthanol et à éthanol et vous avez
réussi à nous le complexifier là
pas fait exprès c'est pas pour être
désagréable
sur sur ces sujets il y a une
littérature scientifique qui est assez
abondante sur le sur le sur l'impact en
gros des biocarburants sur les prix
alimentaires c'est une littérature qui
avait été assez bien résumé mais ça
donne un petit peu par le
hlpech de la FAO qui avait été missionné
sur le sujet et qui montrait un peu un
schéma un peu de ce type là aussi qui
montrait en fait la multiplicité des
canaux par lesquels en fait se fait se
fait l'interaction entre les prix et la
difficulté à extraire des conclusions ça
dépend notamment beaucoup des méthodes
qui sont employées pour pour aborder
cette question là entre des approches
qui sont des approches par modélisation
avec tous les limites qu'on a sur les
modélisations agricoles notamment les
difficultés intégrées des rigidités des
rigidités dans le système dont on sait
qu'elles sont très importantes les
approches par quoi intégration de prix
mais qui font du traitement c'est du
très bon du signal en fait à quelque
part ça ça renseigne pas forcément sur
les causalités enfin voilà il y a
différentes approches sur le sujet mais
c'est assez difficile d'être conclusif
au passage derrière la littérature elle
est surtout elle est surtout américaine
sur le sujet et la américaine alors que
les systèmes d'incorporation aux
États-Unis la politique incorporation
est pas la même qu'en France il y a une
politique d'incorporation qui est assez
ambitieuse aussi aux États-Unis mais pas
identique en France donc on a pas on n'a
pas vraiment de transposition forcément
simple sur le sur le sujet
juste être pour compléter par rapport à
ce que vous avez indiqué si si je peux
me permettre un dernier mot sur le sur
les sur les technologies moi je suis pas
du tout un expert de g3g ce qui est sûr
c'est que la première génération c'est
celle qui est disponible aujourd'hui sur
le marché on est effectivement sur une
technologie qui relativement mature elle
est là depuis quelques années par
rapport à la veille concurrentielle sous
le contrôle de d'horreur il me semble
qu'on a quand même la veille on l'a on
en fait un délai concurrentiel sur des
produits alimentaires également on en
fait sur différents fruits et légumes on
le fait sur le lait on le fait sur un
certain nombre de production alimentaire
et j'ai plus la note en tête pour les
pour les pour le le biogazole et le
bioada mais on est plutôt bon on est
plutôt bien placé c'est-à-dire qu'on a
quand même il veille concurrentiel qui
est plutôt très favorable qui situe bien
la France c'est lié aussi au passage aux
politiques publiques mais si je peux me
permettre je pense que je me trompe pas
c'est à peu près vrai partout c'est à
dire qu'en fait les biocarburants il y a
des politiques publiques à peu près
partout qui est encadrent ou qui
favorise le carburant dans les
différents pays on l'a dit tout à
l'heure pour pour la Thaïlande c'est
vrai au Brésil qui ont qui ont le le
c'est vraiment assez grand chose
impulsion politique que ça s'est
développé également c'est vrai aux
étudier aux États-Unis voilà donc en
gros c'est on a plutôt une une bonne une
bonne compétitivité pour nos filières
même si elles sont pas exemples de
difficultés pour la technologie actuelle
effectivement la difficulté c'est c'est
logique futur on voit que on a on a
aujourd'hui ce que l'on constate aussi
peut-être qu'on peut le dire c'est que
la partie des biocarburants avancé qui
vient compléter qui vient compléter les
vu qu'avant de première génération dans
la corporation c'est principalement des
huiles usagers c'est principalement des
en gros c'est pas la c'est pas la 2G la
3G et qu'on la voit là c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt les c'est plutôt les c'est
plutôt les les résidus en fait qui sont
qui sont aujourd'hui qui font
aujourd'hui ce complément ce complément
et pour juste pour préciser ce que vient
de dire pierre c'est ce qui est marqué
dans un citation à l'école il circulaire
c'est c'est les opposes les mélasses les
marées etc c'est ça et les huiles
usagées c'est ça qui aujourd'hui permet
de dépasser la limite de 7 % qui est
imposé à la à l'incorporation de
biocarburant de première génération
aujourd'hui notre objectif c'est d'aller
c'est d'atteindre 15% dans les
transports alors ils ont 2030 c'est un
objectif communautaire et qui a été
répercuté en France mais aujourd'hui
l'objectif intermédiaire je crois c'est
9,5% pour 2024 c'est ça 2023 2023 9,5%.
et qui qui sera qui ne peut être atteint
qu'avec 7% maximum de Giens et donc de
points et demi avec des biocarburants
avancés ou de la 2G ou la 3G mais autre
chose que de la que de la première
génération alors pour l'instant compte
tenu des difficultés de maturité
technologiques que j'indiquais sur ce
graphique c'est plutôt obtenu par des
produits
issus de l'incitation à l'économie
circulaire plus que par des productions
de G au sens strict du terme ou 3G
simplement on n'a pas la première
génération on peut dire qu'elle a abouti
aujourd'hui et qu'elle est qu'elle est
au top
la première génération et puis quand
cela deuxième génération j'ai bien
compris ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est que
économiquement comme scientifiquement
elle n'est pas au point
parce que il y a des gens qui rêvent à
penser qu'on est déjà à 3 ou 4e
génération
pigment parlant moi j'ai pas de
compétences pour me prononcer là-dessus
le fait que qu'on sorte qu'on ait du mal
à passer pour la pour la deuxième
génération qu'on ait du mal à passer
d'un site pilote à l'échelle
industrielle c'est autant des problèmes
technologiques que des problèmes de
gestion de population de levure ou de
micro-organisme à des échelles
importantes qui sont des problématiques
complexes alors qui relèvent de la
science mais mais je ne sais pas si mais
on peut dire que
la preuve que ça peut marcher ça existe
enfin je veux dire scientifiquement elle
existe cette preuve c'est pas c'est pas
du tout un rêve par contre son
industrialisation pose vraiment problème
économiquement aussi bien sûr économique
juste un point un point d'attention
parce que si jamais vous êtes amené à
regarder les chiffres aux États-Unis aux
États-Unis et il y a c'est le
biocarburants avancés je sais plus c'est
advance plus grand en anglais mais la
catégorie du bicarbonate aux États-Unis
faut pas se tromper avec les faux amis
c'est pas de la 2G ici c'est
essentiellement c'est essentiellement le
bio diesel en mémoire c'est
essentiellement biodel qui fait la qui
fait ce que les Américains appellent
dans les dans la politique incorporation
américaine les bicarbures avancé en gros
c'est ce qui n'est pas l'éthanol mais on
va retrouver essentiellement du milieu
diesel très classique
ce légume
sénatrice de la Nièvre
merci beaucoup écoutez une question qui
qui voit encore plus loin et mais ça
fait partie des choses qui me font un
petit peu rêver est-ce qu'il y a des
recherches et peut-être des pistes
intéressantes sur les la ressource que
pourrait être les plantes invasives
parce que je j'ai toujours imaginé que
une mauvaise herbe c'était celle dont on
avait toujours pas trouvé l'usage mais
quand je pense à la justice la renouée
du Japon si tout d'un coup elle trouvait
un usage ses plantes qui nous coûte très
cher dans tous je sais pas quoi faire on
essaie de les enlever on en voit pas le
voilà si tout d'un coup ça devenait une
ressource intéressante ce serait deux
problèmes qui seraient réglés
simultanément
moi j'ai connaissance de développement
d'usage mais c'est plus sur les produits
biosourcés ou justement je pense que le
fait qu'il y a des hauts de valeur
ajoutée fait qu'on peut
avoir des gisements un peu plus petits
mais j'avais entendu sur les algues
brunes notamment en Bretagne d'essayer
d'en faire des produits biosourcés
sur le sujet c'est que
si on s'intéresse au biocarburant on
parle de produits qui sont quand même
des produits en masse c'est-à-dire pour
que ça a une signification sur le marché
faut arriver à des produits qui sont
relativement importants quantitativement
parlant pour que des filières puissent
exister donc ça c'est un problème ça
veut dire que des plantes invasives de
manière importante ça peut exister il
pourrait y avoir je pense que la renouée
du Japon il y en avait non mais la
question qui va se poser à ce moment-là
c'est ça c'est c'est tout à fait ça la
question qui se pose derrière c'est
est-ce que économiquement parlant les
problèmes posés par la logistique à mon
sont réglé il faut dire une chose c'est
que la première génération sa maturité
il y a une chose qui est vachement
importante c'est que la logistique
alimentaire agroalimentaire règle et
prend en charge la logistique nécessaire
à la première génération s'il fallait
alors aujourd'hui alors la logistique
forestière pourrait imaginer de prendre
en charge la 2G enfin la logistique de
la 2G mais si on devait prendre ex ni
l'eau une logistique du type une plante
dispersée pour lequel il y a aucune
logistique de récolte qui est pris en
compte pour la ramener un lieu de
traitement et la faire en quantité
suffisante pour que ça puisse être un
segment de marché sur les biocarburants
à ce moment-là attention les prix de la
logistique deviendraient tout à fait
important relativement au prix de la
matière première et ça voilà c'est un
c'est des coups masqués qui sont
n'apparaissent pas la 1g c'est la
logistique agricole qui prend en charge
la logistique de la de la première
génération
oui merci normalement on a un poil de
compétitivité autour de la bio économie
on y travaille déjà depuis
un certain nombre de d'années et j'ai
pas vu figurer dans le schéma mais
sûrement que j'ai mal regardé le
principe mais le principe qu'on nous a
toujours un peu inculqué depuis moi
j'étais aux affaires à partir de 2003 ou
on transformait la plante en entier dans
le cas de la bio économie en prônait
toujours l'exemple du blé du blé en
pouvait en faire bien sûr de la farine
mais on pouvait refaire aussi des
produits cosmétologiques avec la paille
en faisait du bioéthanol on remettait
dans le sol c'était le principe des
produits des coproduits où il y avait
plus de sous-produit mais il y avait
toujours derrière une valeur ajoutée
forte non pas autour du bioéthanol parce
que là on peut en faire mais à travers
les molécules portail par exemple le blé
c'était la cosmétologie et c'est ça qui
ramenait et j'ai pas j'ai pas vu dans
l’intérieur du schéma justement le la
partie de la valeur ajoutée la plus
significative vous voyez on fait du
raisin aussi et les raisins on fait du
bon champagne bien entendu mais avec le
pépin de raisin il y a des oxydants et
on le transforme etc voyez-vous je finis
ma question parce que j'en ai une
deuxième donc où est la valeur ajoutée
par rapport à ça parce que effectivement
l'éthanol c'est une partie des
coproduits mais qu'une partie la
betterave on fait de sucre déjà après
les drêches etc maintenant on sait la
pressé les deuxième égouts on arrive à
refaire un tas de trucs de plus en plus
on commence à être au point quand même
il y a eu des investissements chez moi
par centaines de milliers de millions
d'euros quand même et ma deuxième
question ce heurter toujours mais je
pense c'est toujours pareil justement
après le stade pilote parce que ça on
sait faire après on fait les fermenteurs
qui sont quand même plus importants pour
permettre effectivement d'aller au stade
pré-industriel et à toc on est en France
John venture et compagnie et là c'est
des entreprises étrangères qui des
brevets et on va le développer à
l'étranger est-ce qu'il y a une
amélioration par rapport à ça parce que
c'était quand même un facteur limitatif
où on était sur le plan production au
local sur le plan intellectuel
intéressant avec des centres de
recherche des grandes écoles on savait
faire la recherche la recherche
appliquée on savait faire derrière la
transformation pré-industrielle mais
après là ça partait un peu est-ce que ça
avançait et oui où sont les molécules
portail par rapport à ce schéma
alors
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
absent de ce schéma et c'est lié au fait
que ce schéma visait simplement à
expliciter la difficulté à éclairer de
manière simple les relations entrepris
pétrolier pris alimentaire ça ne traite
pas de la totalité de la bio économie et
vous avez parfaitement raison un autre
schéma qui serait peut-être pas beaucoup
plus simple malheureusement mais devrait
traiter aussi des questions sur les
produits bio sourcés mais aussi sur la
méthanisation sur il y a d'autres
aspects la bio économique qui sont pas
pris en compte dans le schéma donc vous
avez tout à fait raison de le constater
c'est vrai et puis ensuite sur la
deuxième question sur truc j'ai pas
énormément de compétences sur le sujet
la seule chose que je peux dire c'est
que il y a une usine qui a été
développée aux États-Unis pour traiter
les les
parties les cannes de maïs qui étaient
une usine d'Abengoa et qui a
malheureusement été obligé de fermer
parce que ça marchait pas et donc même
aux États-Unis lorsqu'il y a pu passer
lorsqu'il y a eu
passage à l'échelle industrielle pour la
2G et bien ça s'est révélé être un échec
économique donc c'est bien sûr il y a
peut-être des difficultés de de je
dirais d'accompagnement R&D en France
spécifique je ne sais pas je me prononce
pas dessus j'ai aucune aucune compétence
sur le sujet mais en tout cas sur le
passage ça a eu lieu le passage
industriel aux États-Unis et ça n'a pas
marché voilà
simplement en complément la réponse de
Patrick sur le sur la partie volume
valeur donc pas sur ce schéma là
effectivement mais on a bien conscience
quand on a présenté le nb on est en
volume et donc on prend on traite des
grandes masses et on traite pas à ce que
je l'ai indiqué en traite pas la rentrée
pas la relation par contre on a quand
même ces questions là en
les a bien en tête et on a une étude on
a une étude qui doit être bientôt fini
sur les sur les sur les molécules
plateformes également justement sur
cette notion de molécule plateforme ça a
des molécules qui sont qui sont à forte
valorisation et de valorisation
notamment on est en éventail avec plus
qui sert en gros après être composé en
chimie mais ça doit être la même je
pense que c'est le même on pense à la
même chose
Béatrice Gosselin sénatrice de la Manche
oui qui est vraiment de base
parce que
vous entendez à propos des est-ce que ce
sont les coquilles des moules etc voilà
ça je ne connaissais pas et pour le
poisson vous m'expliquerez aussi et la
deuxième c'est un peu plus politique et
peut-être un petit peu plus polémique
c'est de se dire vous parlez de deux
ministères différents celui qui vous
gère et celui de développement durable
etc est-ce que la ce qu'on a entendu
dire à propos des carburants de première
génération
bio-carburant qui sont plutôt en phase
un peu décroissante au niveau de
l'utilisation et est-ce que est-ce que
l'un le l'effet est dû au fait que vous
n'êtes pas forcément la même le même
optique ou la même le même objectif
c'est peut-être un petit peu politique
mais en gros est-ce que le est-ce que le
développement durable enfin les missions
vraiment qui nous qui nous qui gère
notre pays actuellement influe pas un
peu sur l'évolution ou non de ce
biocarburant
je réponds sur la deuxième question mais
je vais te répondre de la première sur
la sur la question de je sais pas
comment dire je l'ai indiqué au fond les
politiques publiques sont très
importants dans la structuration de de
ces filières là et encore une fois c'est
vrai partout dans le monde et les
objectifs d'incorporation c'est
l'objectifs qui sont des objectifs qui
sont fixés par par la par la loi ou pas
en l'occurrence aussi des des directives
européennes et qui sont fruits compromis
et compromis qui sont qui sont trouvés
au niveau des au niveau des au niveau
des instances politiques donc moi je
vais pas me prononcer sur le sujet mais
effectivement il y a différentes il y a
différentes comment dire il y a
différentes dimensions qui sont prises
en qui sont prises en considération et
qui vont amener aux résultats non pas
jugé ça mais ce qui est sûr
effectivement c'est que c'est politique
là elles sont essentielles dans le dans
le devenir des dans le devenir de de ces
filières voilà après effectivement
pourquoi pourquoi on fixe un niveau ou
un autre je pense qu'il y a
effectivement au fond un simplement un
compromis qui est trouvé complétez j'ai
cru comprendre aussi que l'Allemagne
faisait plutôt une un choix de l'import
plutôt que de produire vraiment donc
voilà encore une décision qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas sans conséquence à la fois
sur le développement durable et sur le
bilan carbone
c'est surtout sur l'hydrogène qui font
le choix de l'import oui plutôt mais
pour prolonger la question de ma
collègue transition du président la
question parce que ce que je comprends
ce que vous dites plutôt c'est que vous
ne dites les politiques publiques
influent beaucoup donc la conclusion
c'est si on défendait un taux
d'incorporation plus important vous
dites tu aurais plus de production mais
est-ce que voilà est-ce qu'on saurait
répondre
je pense que ça ça sera professionnel
aux industriels de répondre je pense que
ça dépend à quel niveau on le placerait
je pense que si on a monté d'un pour
cent ça poserait pas forcément de
difficulté sur l'augmentation doubler le
taux là je sais pas ça ce serait
vraiment aux industriels de répondre sur
la capacité à le faire encore une fois
le
ça permet de rebondir quand sur ce que
vous étiez sur l'Allemagne l'Allemagne
elle importe notre colossa au passage
quand même notamment on a on a le c'est
c'est filières là elles ont quand même
contribué pour le coup aussi à renforcer
la souveraineté alimentaire ou en tout
cas éviter ça ça dégradation sur un
certain nombre de de sur un simple de
production c'est le cas pour les c'est
le cas pour le complexe oléagineux on
l'a dit ça vaut le coup d'être rappelé
je pense aussi sur
sur ces sur ces sujets là parmi les
considérations à prendre en compte ça en
fait partie c'est qu'en gros il y a pas
de je sais pas à commander le dire il y
a quelque part forcément l'arbitrage qui
relève qui aurait du politique entre ces
différentes dimensions mais en tout cas
il y a des il y a des vertus en gros qui
sont apportées sur vraiment la partie
capacités à capacité à développer sur
des taux supérieurs moi j'ai le
sentiment en tout cas que là on est sur
un niveau qui a pas beaucoup bougé ces
dernières années ça ça a la vertu en
gros de donner de la stabilité et de la
prévisibilité pour les acteurs
économiques si ça bougeait forcément ça
c'est de l'industrie un peu lourde donc
ça ça juste pas immédiatement je sais
pas si ça si ça si ça serait
problématique si ça si ça augmentait un
tout petit peu si ça augmentait beaucoup
ça j'imagine que c'est c'est plus
difficile mais ça c'est plutôt à mon
avis aux industriels que de lire et
est-ce qu'on répond peut-être pour les
poissons et les
très rapidement
ce qu'on a traité là sur le sur les
moules et sur les huîtres ce sont bien
bien évidemment vous avez raison c'est
les coquilles et sur les coquilles
Saint-Jacques également et sur les
poissons c'est les peaux les têtes les
arêtes etc donc c'est l'utilisation
principalement des coproduits puisque
comme le disait Aurore notre objet actif
dans le NRB c'est de collationner des
informations sur les usages non
alimentaires de la biomasse dernière
pression je me permets juste une
pression pour ajouter à ce que dit
Pierre sans rentrer dans le débat
polémique la CTI cherche à entre
guillemets interfacer les professionnels
avec plusieurs ministères et pas
simplement le MTE on a le MTE la DGE
donc la Direction Générale des
Entreprises du ministère de l'Économie
et également Ministère de la Recherche
l'INRA l'inrae est autour de la table
etc et l'épaule aussi l'épaule à
coupimer et bien sûr bi forcing etc les
épaules sont aussi autour de la table
donc on cherche à à comment s'appelle
à interfacer mais voilà mais nous sommes
sous tutelle du ministère de
l'Agriculture
sauf que vous partagez aussi avec
l'environnement j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure quand même et là c'est là où ça
se complique
partie une berthèse sénatrice de la
Savoie
le grand producteur de colza
oui est-ce que vous pouvez
solution un technologie qui fonctionne
et qui a déjà été mise en œuvre enfin
qui est mise en oeuvre déjà sur les
aspects justement l'aspect économique
social je pense par exemple pour la
première génération les sujets d'eau par
rapport au manque d'eau etc qui commence
cette troisième génération peut prendre
sa place est-ce qu'il y a un sujet de
volume comment est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus sur vos observations
merci
je laisserai aussi la parole à Aurore
pour que elle complète ma réponse
les aspects que vous abordez en la
question nous ont amené nous interroger
sur serait les critères de performance
de la bio économie et pas simplement sur
le plan économique mais également sur le
plan environnemental et sur le plan
social c'est-à-dire sur les trois
piliers de la durabilité
sachant comme ça a été précisé par
Pierre en introduction nous n'avons pas
de compétences environnementales ni
social enfin je veux dire c'est pas
notre métier donc ça veut dire que c'est
notre rôle d'agrégateur d'information
qui nous permettent tenter de ça et
justement ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
sur l'interface qu'on cherche à mettre
en avant un terme ministériel sur le
sujet qui nous permet d'avancer sur ces
questions là sur plan de sur le plan de
la 3G on sait qu'il y a des usines de
micro-algues qui font de l'extraction
d'huile de microalgue pour faire des
biods je sais qu'il y en a une en
Espagne voilà et à partir donc on est
passé à la à l'échelle industrielle mais
je sais aussi et je vais passer la
parole à
des publications qui aujourd'hui disent
que voilà que ça coûte cher sur le plan
énergétique etc c'est pas voilà que tout
n'est pas parfait dans toutes les
directions voilà et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles il faudra qu'on
ait des grilles de lecture qui soit sur
les trois piliers de la durabilité et
ensuite ensuite une chose très bête
c'est qu'en terme énergétique c'est un
peu comme la nutrition la variété ça a
vraisemblablement du bon quoi
effectivement j'avais lu un article
scientifique qui regardait les critères
environnementaux sociaux économiques qui
faisaient une agrégation et en fait
les algues étaient pas parmi les
meilleurs
micro-algues notamment à cause de du
coût énergétique pour pour faire des
fonctionnalités
donc en fait ça d'avoir des énergies
propres si on veut avoir un bon score
donc à l'heure actuelle c'était pas le
plus favorable donc dans cette étude
c'était plutôt les déchets ménagers qui
étaient favorisés sachant que le
problème c'était le volume disponible on
produit pas une quantité infinie de
déchets ménagers et le second
un sur Paris en ce moment c'est bon il y
a un bon gisement là
mais après sur le deuxième meilleur
c'était les bio diesel
issus des huiles parce que même si elles
ont des facteurs environnementaux forts
en fait rapporter au kilomètre parcouru
c'était plus performant donc d'un point
de vue social environnemental et
économique les bio diesels étaient
meilleurs
et par rapport à la question tout à
l'heure effectivement l'Allemagne
importait de l'huile de palme parce
qu'ils avaient pas les mêmes critères
environnementaux
que nous en fait ce qui favorisait
c'était le score de gaz à effet de serre
EMI et l'huile de palme avec son
rendement et très efficiente par rapport
au volume produit donc ils importaient
une ville de palme
les exporter d'autres matières premières
de chez eux dans d'autres pays qui
n'avaient pas les mêmes critères
environnementaux
merci de tous ces éléments alors nous on
est en recherche de pilotage si je puis
dire donc on est un niveau plus
on essaye un truc d'arriver à un niveau
un peu plus stratégique
de ce que vous nous dites moi je
comprends que en première génération ça
marche plutôt bien il y a un volume qui
est plutôt stable
bon
que si on devait augmenter
vous me dites 1% de plus d'incorporation
ce genre de choses si vous êtes
atteignable vous allez voir comment ça
réagit on ira pas forcément plus donc
sur un scénario de stabilité
je caricature peut-être bon je comprends
aussi c'est ce que le président tout à
l'heure c'est que sur la deuxième
génération vous nous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure monsieur aigrin
la partie industrialisation et la partie
viabilité économique et pas évidente
donc là aussi je me déstabilisé
bon et puis je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure on a entendu la dame on a
entendu la cour alors la DM il y a son
étude dites transition 2050 ou en gros
l'idée c'est une faible évolution des
bioénergie
le RTE est plutôt sur un scénario de
production stable
si j'ai bien compris avec 12
terawattheure de bioénergie d'ici 2050
encore
la cour que nous avons additionné
même plus que des doutes sur
l'impact climatique des biocarburants et
sous-entend même
j'ai un peu honte à le dire mais que
c'est peut-être une façon de rémunérer
les agriculteurs plus qu'une façon de
contribuer à la décarbonation désolé de
je dis pas que je reprends ça à mon
compte je dis ce que j'ai entendu
c'était quand même dit exclusivement bon
on avait peut-être un point
d'interrogation à la fin mais à peine et
puis Transport et Environnement qui est
venu devant notre mission
de la semaine dernière où il y a 15
jours je sais plus le temps passe vite
et qui nous a dit que on pourrait
peut-être
faire que les terres actuellement
exploités pour produire des
biocarburants soit mieux employés pour
séquestrer du carbone ou pour nourrir
les populations bon donc tout cela c'est
plutôt des questionnements et de dire
l'orientation
la possibilité d'orientation est plutôt
comme dit tout à l'heure avec une
formule un peu osée au toboggan bon
alors disons il faudrait peut-être
certains de me dire il faut réfléchir à
fermer la filière quoi enfin ou du moins
à ce que ça représenterait comme
casse industrielle et sociale s'il a
filière était en décroissance forte bon
donc
de votre tableau tout à l'heure moi je
conclus que comme tout est très
compliqué peut-être que finalement il
faut garder en tout cas au moins une
veille et un outil suffisant parce que
ça peut aussi repartir
bon ben vous dire dans ce cas là on a
pas conclu grand chose on tourne un peu
en rond mais quelles sont les facteurs
de risque enfin en gros les différents
réseaux et facteurs de risque qui pèsent
sur cette filière est-ce qu'on peut les
traiter parce que aujourd'hui ce qu'on
comprend des pouvoirs publics qui est
pas simple à comprendre c'est quand même
que grosso modo il faut quand même
garder un peu tous les outils
on fait des appels à manifestation
d'intérêt de tous ces immutes on regarde
bien ce qui sort et puis un jour ou
l'autre la fumée blanche sortira donc
pour se dire on arrête rien entre temps
voilà mais du coup voilà qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire pour nous éclairer
sur les
bon les parents je trouve vraiment en
français enfin les guidances les
orientations majeures qu'on peut avoir
pour demain
une réponse je suis pas sûr d'avoir la
réponse définitive sur cette question là
d'abord les biocarburants si on les
pense en terme de politique énergétique
moi j'ai pas la réponse parce que le mix
énergétique souhaitable pour la France
c'est pas mon c'est pas mon champ de
compétence je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de dimensions à intégrer il y a beaucoup
de dimensions qu'il faut qui sont pas
que économique encore une fois vers le
un pays qui maîtrise pas son mix
énergétique je fais ça me semble un peu
difficile mais encore une fois je sors
de mon champ de compétent que j'irai pas
plus loin que ce que cette phrase là
donc il y a des éléments je pense à
prendre en compte qui sont pas que qui
sont pas que qui sont pas que notre cas
strictement économique strictement en
gros la compétitivité ou la ou la
maturité était technologique je pense
beaucoup d'autres dimensions à prendre
en compte mais c'est pas à moi de c'est
pas moi d'aller approfondir ce sujet là
d'un point de vue agricole qu'on connaît
un peu mieux et je vois pas les
difficultés que ça a créé ces filières
là en tout cas pour le monde agricole
français là ça a plutôt servi
comme un débouché complémentaire à ceux
qui existaient ça permet en gros de
diversifier un minimum les sources de
les sources de revenus de la filière
alors pas forcément de l'agriculture il
y a un moment des au moins des filières
à des filières avales donc du point de
vue agricole en tout cas ça c'est pas il
y a pas je vois pas la difficulté que ça
crée en tout cas dès lors qu'on est sur
des sur des sur des cultures pour
lesquelles on n'a pas non plus en France
de de de
grands problèmes liés à la déforestation
par exemple donc c'est je peux répondre
du point de vue agricole après du point
de vue énergétique vraiment ce cépage
j'ai pas la compétence pour vous dire
qu'elle devrait être le bon mix
énergétique je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de dimensions qu'il faudrait intégrer
qui sont pas sur lesquels on a on n'a
pas grand chose à dire à François
Grimmer maintenant tu veux compléter
quand même
juste un mot pour dire que si on devait
regarder les chocs qui attendent ces
filières à terme il y en a un mais vous
l'avez certainement pris en compte c'est
le fait c'est éventuellement
l'interdiction des moteurs thermiques
thermiques je ne sais pas ce que ça va
donner effectivement puisque il y a
certains États qui sont prononcés en
disant que ils appliqueraient pas les
directives enfin en tout cas que c'était
pas d'accord pour la mettre en œuvre
mais en tout cas voilà ça le choc qui a
devant c'est clair puisque une partie
importante bien évidemment de
l'utilisation du bioéthanol du biodiel
c'est les flottes de véhicules et les
flottes de véhicules privées donc c'est
sûr que si on passe si on abandonne
définitivement le moteur thermique voilà
et ça c'est clair que ça pose ensuite
faudra faudra regarder mais ça c'est pas
non plus notre compétence mais il faut
regarder toutes les ACV vraiment de
l'extraction toutes les matières
premières nécessaires jusqu'à la fin
pour regarder ce qui est bon entre les
voitures thermiques et les voitures
électriques
voilà ce qu'on a entre les mains comme
étude disent qu'il faut garder les
voitures électriques plus de 6 ans pour
que ça aille le coup parce que avant
avant c'est pas c'est pas extraordinaire
donc c'est pas extraordinaire en terme
de l'analyse de cyclos de vie donc ça
c'est des débats très très compliqués
sur lesquels nous on est notre sol rôle
c'est vraiment concentrer les
informations diffuser l'information les
sourcées donc bien évidemment on a on a
les scénarios de la dame dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure
monsieur le rapporteur on les a bien sûr
présenté et discuter dans dans nos
instances on n'est pas capable de porter
des jugements de valeur là-dessus et
enfin je veux dire c'est pas notre c'est
pas notre métier
en matière agricole il y a au moins
trois aspects qui peuvent être prises en
compte là dessus c'est que
historiquement parlant mais je pense que
il y a un certain nombre de gens qui ont
encore ça en tête c'est vrai que
le développement des biocarburants
en Europe et notamment France a été
l'utilisation de la jachère la jachère
industrielle voilà c'est ça qui a donc
ça a été des actes de politique agricole
au départ ok aujourd'hui ça reste
peut-être pas simplement des actes de
politique alcool ça reste aussi des
actes de politique énergétique je disais
tout à l'heure en me permettant pas
beaucoup d'aller beaucoup plus loin que
ce que disait pierre c'est peut-être que
la variété c'est une prudence en matière
de mix énergétique sachant quand même
que la biomasse dans la matière en
matière énergétique c'est
la portion congrue vers cet outil donc
mais est-ce que cette variété n'est pas
utile moi j'en sais rien enfin en tout
cas on n'a pas de d'opinion sur le sujet
en tant que tel mais c'est vrai que
voilà ça ça ferait de la diversification
sur l'ensemble de la bio économie et si
on la considère considère l'usage
énergétique comme un des usages
possibles de la biomasse c'est-à-dire et
c'est un des usages qui ne trouvent de
l'intérêt que si les autres usages sont
également remplis c'est à dire vous
parlez tout à l'heure de l'extraction de
la molécule d'intérêt des biomatériaux
etc c'est cette cascade du sage qu'il
faut considérer à mon avis pour pour
regarder la totalité de ce que ça donne
dans l'économie agricole et même y
compris sur le plan social et
environnemental c'est ça qu'il faut
considérer sa complexifie bien sûr le
paysage mais ça fait partie des éléments
à mon avis à prendre en compte et
ensuite ça ça va jouer à des niveaux qui
sont à la fois microéconomiques pour les
exploitations
et puis
macroéconomique pour la régulation des
filières
voilà je pense que c'est la totalité de
ces éléments là qui sont qui sont à
intégrer du point de vue agricole et
aussi du point de vue énergétique
aujourd'hui par exemple la Béthanie la
méthanisation c'est quelque chose qui
est considéré comme pas complètement
absurde en termes en termes énergétique
sur le plan du gaz voilà
mais c'est pas ça sera aux énergéticiens
de se prononcer sur sur le développement
de ces aspects là
parce qu'en terme énergétique
excusez-moi juste pour finir en termes
énergétique on a au moins trois trois
éléments à prendre en compte c'est
principalement à partir de la forêt à la
chaleur
puis le gaz à travers le
biométhane etc
sachant que de manière un peu
un peu surprenante on a intérêt à
produire du CO2 et à le capter parce
qu'on est on a besoin de CO2
industriellement etc le CO2 diffusion
atmosphère c'est une catastrophe pour
les pour
le gaz à effet de serre mais
industriellement parlant il faut en
produire donc voilà donc le biométhane
ça peut produit aussi du CO2 voilà donc
il y a et puis et puis toutes les Val
orisés agricoles non alimentaire autre
que l'usage catabolique qui est vraiment
usage catabolique c'est vraiment l'usage
final quoi c'est quand on peut plus rien
faire d'autre
pardon de ce que vous nous dites d'abord
je réagis sur le sur l'annonce d'hier et
sur la question de
du moteur thermique avec un sujet sur la
définition de ce que peuvent pourront
être les carburants dit durables
synthétiques et en quelle mesure la
filière peut aussi raccrocher ou pas
après il y a peut-être une stratégie de
niche aussi qu'on peut garder dans
certaines types d'usage
peut-être ça peut se regarder ça
j'imagine
ok en tout cas merci votre réponse qui
était très riche
papa condamné trop vite tout ça parce
qu'il y a eu des efforts qui ont été
faits on a donné des espoirs à travers
ça il y a eu des investissements quand
même lourds il faut quand même finir de
les rentabiliser puis d'autre part
mettre tous ses œufs dans le même panier
à mon avis c'est pas la solution à
l'avenir quand même soyons attentif à
cela on voit bien que les les effets les
effets médiatiques sur ces filières là
sont d'une redoutable
inefficacité régulièrement donc je pense
que à travers la mission faut quand même
montrer qu'il y a on n'a pas fait
quelque chose qui est
anti anti planétaire il y a sûrement il
y a maintenant des efforts à faire par
rapport à ce qu'on a fait auparavant
mais il faut pas détruire ce qui a pu
marcher parce qu'on aura besoin encore
du monde agricole pour alimenter mais
aussi pour faire en sorte de transformer
la plante en entier à mon avis puis on
va regarder le couvrir un certain nombre
de choses on voit bien les limites de
tout électrique
on va voir les limites et peut-être
qu'on verra des limites plus graves et
si on est abandonné
nos filières après existantes on aura
encore bonne mine
on est là dans un exercice qui de
confrontation et forcément quand on a
reçu la filière hydrogène la semaine
dernière
on a essayé de les pousser dans leur
tranchement aussi pour dire
ne nous dit pas simplement que
l'hydrogène c'est l'avenir et que c'est
formidable et qu'il faut rien changer et
qui voilà bon donc on essaie de vous
challenger pour prendre ce mot là pardon
mais mais merci d'accepter ça juste de
questions vous parlez de l'étranger des
USA notamment donc là-dessus est-ce que
vous avez des montres comparaison enfin
qu'est-ce qu'on sait dire des politiques
qui sont conduites là-bas qu'est-ce
qu'on sait dire qu'il pourrait nous
inspirer d'ailleurs peut-être et puis
deuxièmement sur la biomasse là
pour être clair sur un peu abordé mais
quel est le type de biomasse agricole
qui vous paraît le plus disponible et le
plus prometteur pour demain
on la regarde assez attentivement même
si c'est pas toujours c'est pas toujours
facile mais on partage les évolutions de
politique avec les dans le cas du du GT
biocarburant
d'ailleurs les comment dire les
acteurs industriels sont aussi attentifs
à ce qui se passe là-bas donc on a des
échanges assez intéressants ils ont des
ils ont une politique qui ressemblent
globalement c'est quelqu'un une
obligation d'incorporation ils ont un
certain nombre de subtilités qu'on a pas
comme des systèmes de ring qu'on a pas
en France dans notre capacité à une
capacité à reporter en gros les
obligations d'aller sur l'autre à
échanger des obligations d'incorporation
après voilà il y a un centre de
différence cette politique là elle a un
intérêt qui on peut regarder le prix du
le cours d'urine donc le aérienne
je crois qui est en gros le qui est en
gros cette capacité qu'on a à transférer
ou à de données sur l'autre ou un autre
obligé finalement ces obligations
Corporation et qu'on peut voir en gros
le coût de la contrainte associé à
l'incorporation c'est ce qu'on n'a pas
en France en France on peut pas mesurer
en gros le caractère plus ou moins
contraignant et et au fait dalle aux
États-Unis quand le système quand le
marché fonctionne bien ce qui est pas
toujours le cas est-ce que ça marche
assez compliqué de marcher de du
aérienne avec pas mal de de débat
là-dessus mais c'est un marché qui quand
il fonctionne bien permet par contre de
voir ça de voir aussi par contre le le
l'évolution de l'évolution du coût de la
contrainte ou de l'importance de la
contrainte selon l'évolution du cours
c'était horror si tu veux compléter
sur les États-Unis ce qu'on peut dire
c'est enfin alors c'est un peu plus
large que juste la politique de
corporation mais
leur appui à la recherche c'est
considéré comme un atout ils ont une
politique
d'investissement dans la recherche qui
est très forte
ce qu'on a noté aussi c'est que ils ont
une recherche sur les sélections
variétales
favorables et ils utilisent des OGM là
bas aussi pour les bocarburant donc ça
peut être considéré comme un atout
économique
après
il y avait le fait qu'ils ont un marché
intérieur qui m'apporte leur filière
ils ont moins d'opposants au bioéthanol
justement même si un conflit il y a un
conflit pétrolier et bio carburant quand
même à noter
voilà ce qu'on peut résumer rapidement
je pense
des matières premières avec un coût
limité et
[Musique]
globalement oui des taxes des règlements
phytosanitaires recherche qui sont
favorables
et la deuxième question j'ai oublié la
deuxième question
en fait d'un point de vue gisement c'est
les cultures alimentaires qui donnent
les plus gros gisements de copro en fait
donc vous aurez beaucoup de
culture enfin c'est le blé en France
c'est disponible et la forêt c'est vrai
qu'on nous voit toujours la forêt nous
on oublie toujours
50 50 % de 50 % de ressources en
biomasse en masse avec tout ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur le fait que la
masse comme ça mesurait globalement à la
louche c'est pas très très précis mais
c'est 50% des ressources en biomasses
c'est de la forêt
la différence principale entre la forêt
et l'agriculture c'est que la on n'est
pas spécialiste de la forêt à France non
plus mais enfin c'est pas ils sont pas
très loin c'est que on s'est assez bien
extraire on sait bien c'est bien
extraire la biomasse la biomasse
agricole c'est plus compliqué pour la
glace forestière l'accès l'accès l'accès
à la ressource forestière et de faire
l'accès la valorisation est toujours
difficile mais enfin j'imagine que vous
avez déjà étudié ces questions là
après les cultures qui ont le vent en
poupe il y a un chanvre miscanthus mais
ça reste des en terme de surface ça
reste moindre que nous culture
traditionnelles
maïs blé etc
demain il y a peut-être des opportunités
aussi sur les sites c'est-à-dire qu'un
des moyens aussi de éventuellement si on
considérait ce que les chiffres ne
montrent pas à l'heure actuelle mais on
considéré qu'il pouvait y avoir une
concurrence d'usage sur le sol il y a
aussi une manière de de développer des
cultures intermédiaires qui permettent
en utilisant pas plus de sol d'augmenter
d'augmenter la production par unité de
surface par exemple c'est ce qu'on
appelle les cultures intermédiaires à
vocation énergétique qui pourrait
permettre de faire ça ce qui ont aussi
d'autres avantages c'est que
généralement c'est des cultures qu'on
peut qu'on peut faire fonctionner sans
beaucoup d'apports d'engrais etc et
surtout il y a un des intérêts c'est que
quand il y a pas de sol nu il y a moins
de d'évacuation dans l'atmosphère de NOx
c'est à dire de pardon excusez-moi
jargonne
d'Oxy qui sont des
des choses qui ont des pouvoirs
comment s'appelle le gaz à effet de
serre qui sont très élevés beaucoup plus
aidé et beaucoup plus élevés que le CO2
je crois que le rap le ratio c'est 400
fois donc c'est c'est énorme donc le
fait de couvrir les sols ça aussi des ça
aussi un interven environnemental voilà
il y a des pistes de cette nature mais
Aurore a raison en termes de en termes
de grandeur les cultures alimentaires
sur la version agricole c'est bien
évidemment ce qui produira le plus de de
coproduit peut-être une question enfin
pour terminer et qui me rassurerait au
début du début des biocarburants
il y a une directive européenne qui a
permis de lancer des objectifs et des
financements à savoir que il avait été
défini qu'on pourrait atteindre 2010%
d'énergie renouvelables liquide
en 2010 c'était
de date que j'avais bien retenu ça veut
dire que les outils industriels qui ont
été je rejoins dans le prolongement la
question de René Paul Savary les outils
industriels ont été montés avec une
capacité aujourd'hui qui est supérieure
à l'usage actuellement ça veut dire
qu'on a une marge de manœuvre qui
aujourd'hui
on est en salle de peut-être de
l'optimum et qui il faudrait qu'on fasse
fonctionner les outils plus à fond ça
veut dire que si vous partagez mon idée
ça veut dire qu'il faut que l'on puisse
augmenter vous avez dit tout à l'heure
d'un pour cent
moi j'ai cru comprendre en écoutant des
filières
de mon côté que on ne peut atteindre
9,2%
. est-ce que je me trompe ou pas c'est
pour qu'on le mette dans le rapport
le chiffre de 1% génit c'est pour dire à
1%, je pense qu'il est si on est sûr
qu'il y a pas de difficultés c'est ça
que je voulais dire j'ai pas dit que
c'était le maximum atteignable je pense
que je disais je pense que c'est
effectivement c'est les acteurs
industriels qui vont pouvoir répondre à
cette question là mais effectivement
vous avez raison de le rappeler c'était
on a vu cet objectif là de 10 % qui est
sur lesquels qui a servi de cap aussi
effectivement pour l'élaboration des
outils donc mais je pense que les
industriels répondront à ces assez
simplement à ces questions là la
volumétrie cible d'un outil industriel
il y a que l'industriel qui le connaît
le mieux en tout cas alors je vous ai
posé la question tout à l'heure mais en
fait vous n'avez pas répondu c'est en
économie
l'énergie consommée par rapport à
l'énergie restituée
c'est quelque chose qu'on nous oppose
souvent en disant ça coûte trop
la question ça va être les ça va être
les le niveau de critères de durabilité
qu'on va imposer pour pouvoir être
qualifié de biocarburant pour les
productions des cultures c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qu'on va qu'est-ce qu'on va
dépenser en termes d'engrais en termes
de tout les systèmes alors pour
l'instant aujourd'hui
ce sont des ce sont des zones qui sont
considérés comme
produisant dans des conditions
agronomiques qui sont moins dépensières
énergétiquement et que que des zones
traditionnelles et qui permettent de de
considérer que les critères de
durabilité sont sont respectés a priori
les directives européennes qui sont sur
la table aujourd'hui vont continuer à
augmenter
le degré d'exigence de durabilité
relativement à la référence fossile
alors la référence fossile c'est aussi
un débat technique qui est loin d'être
simple c'est à dire c'est on compare le
le coût de production énergétique je
dirais pour obtenir un bio liquide qui
puisse être un biocarberon relativement
à quelque chose qui serait directement
un produit petrossé et donc il y a à la
fois comment est-ce qu'on mesure la
dépense énergétique pour produire un bio
liquide et la deuxième facteur
d'incertitude c'est comment est-ce qu'on
mesure le le coût de production réelle
d'un d'un produit pétrolier de même
nature c'est loin d'être évident parce
que pour l'instant
je sais pas comment est pris en compte
dans le calcul les gaz et les pétroles
de schiste qui sont maintenant des des
acteurs importants du marché des des
carburants fossiles je sais pas comment
sont pris en compte les frais de
prospection du monde pétrolier
il y a toute une série d'incertitudes et
là ça s'est simplifié dernièrement sur
le plan réglementaire parce que
maintenant nous n'avons plus qu'une
seule référence fossile mais avant
lorsque nous avions deux textes avant
l'arrêt de Intex sur les objectifs de
réincorporation et un autre texte une
autre directive européenne qui se qui
traitait de la qualité des carburants et
bien les références fossiles n'étaient
pas les mêmes
voilà on vient juste de les homogéniser
dans le texte de l'arête 2 c'est-à-dire
maintenant on a une seule référence
fossile mais ce sont des enjeux très
importants pour mesurer de la réelle
durabilité pour mesurer de la réelle
durabilité des des biocarbures
parce que souvent quand on est une
énergie nouvelle ou une source nouvelle
on la compare à personne et il faudrait
comparer les coûts du pétrole
effectivement si j'introduis dans le
corps du pétrole les coups de guerre
pour aller défendre cette ressource et
sur la raméolite je crois que si on
prend les biocarburants entre le champ
et le réservoir d'un véhicule
les ratios là on aurait des critères
intéressants
on revient à ce que disait pierre tout à
l'heure sur le fait que en matière
énergétique il y a aussi des questions
de souveraineté
qui sont aussi des questions à prendre
en compte et sur lequel nous n'avons
strictement aucune compétence nous
sommes désolés
et juste pour compléter sur cette
question la durabilité je pense que
c'est une des filières qui a eu le plus
à faire ses preuves sur le sujet pour
pour
vu contenu un des débats qui a eu sur le
sur les questions foot versus etc c'est
une des filières qui a eu le plus à
faire ses preuves et du coup ils ont
développé des schémas certification
volontaire un des sujets j'en profite
pour parler des défis pour demain un des
sujets je pense ça va être effectivement
la traçabilité pour le coup de de la
biomasse qui va qui va être incorporée
parce qu'on voit qu'effectivement il y a
de la pétanque pour les les huiles
usagées par exemple mais par contre
c'est pas toujours facile de savoir si
l'huile elle est vraiment une huile
usagée ou si ça ou si ça n'est pas une
et on a on a effectivement un sujet par
rapport à ça qui est effectivement la
traçabilité des des fils qui sait quand
même largement renforcé je pense sur ces
sur ces sur ces sur ces productions
merci monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
non messieurs les commissaires morts
sénateurs pas de question madame
eh ben écoute on va vous remercier et on
va vous libérer et merci de votre
disponibilité vous n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer les documents voilà et merci
merci bon retour